let's say that we've got two matrices
and i'll just for simplicity i'll start
with two two by two matrices so let's
say that this first one right over here
is
two
negative two
five
and let's say
five and three and then i have this
matrix right over here
that it's also going to be two by two
and let's say it's negative one
let's say 7 and
negative 6.
and what i want to go through in this
video what i want to introduce you to is
the is the convention the mathematical
convention for multiplying two matrices
like this and i want to stress that
because mathematicians could have come
up with a bunch of different ways to
define matrix multiplication but the
convention that i'm going to show you is
is the way that it is done and it's done
this way especially as you go into
deeper linear algebra classes or you
start doing computer graphics or even
modeling different types of phenomena
you'll see why this type of matrix
multiplication which i'm about to show
you why it has the most applications but
i really want to stress this is a human
construct humans have found defining
matrix multiplication the way i'm about
to show you to be useful so let's just
think about how this could how this
could be and once again i want to stress
it's a human construct there's several
ways that you could have thought about
multiplying two two by two matrices you
could have done it the same way that you
add matrices when you add matrices both
matrix both matrices have to have the
same dimensions and you just add the
corresponding entries in the matrices so
why don't we one convention could have
been why don't we just for the
for a product right over here
why don't we
why don't we just multiply corresponding
entries so 2 times negative 1 would put
a negative 2 here negative 2 times 4 put
a negative 8 here that's how we did
addition we added corresponding entries
but that is not the convention for
multiplying matrices that is not the
standard convention
the standard convention for multiplying
matrices is we're essentially going to
take to get this to get this top left
entry right over here we're going to
take the product of
this row
of that row
with this column right over here now
what does it mean to take the product of
a row and a column and if you are
familiar with vector dot products this
might ring a bell where you take the
product of the corresponding terms the
product of the first terms products of
the second terms and then add those
together and so that's essentially what
we're going to be doing we're going to
be taking the dot product of this first
row in this first column to get this top
left entry right over here if the word
dot product makes no sense to you i will
show you what that actually means so
actually let me let me give let's get
some more real estate here just so i
think it'll be useful especially this
very first time that we attempt to
multiply to multiply matrices so this
top left entry it's going to be
2 times negative 1
so 2 times negative 1
plus negative 2
plus
negative 2
times 7
plus negative 2 times 7. so notice i
took the product first entry in the row
first entry in the column those two
products then the product of second
entry in the row second entry in the
column that's right over there and then
i added them together and that's
essentially taking the dot product of
this row vector and this column vector
that doesn't make sense to you if you're
not familiar with vectors and dot
products don't worry about it we just
took the first end product of the first
entry product of the second entry added
them together to get this is going to
give us some number and we'll calculate
that in a few seconds but let's think
about the other ones so to get
this
to get this entry right over here we're
going to take the first row from this
matrix and the second column
from
from this matrix and that kind of makes
sense because this is we're still in the
first row but we're in the second column
of the first row right here first row
second column so it's going to be 2
times 4
2 times 4
plus negative 2
plus negative 2 times negative 6.
and at this point i encourage you to
pause the video seeing what you just saw
see if you could complete this see if
you can figure out the bottom left entry
and the bottom right entry and i'll give
you a clue it has something to do with
this second row here so i'm assuming
you've given a go at it now let's just
let's just power through it together
sometimes matrix multiplication can get
a little bit intense
so we're now in the second row so we're
going to use the second row of this
first matrix and for this entry second
row first column second row first column
five times negative one
five times negative one plus three times
seven plus three
times seven and then finally we're in
the home stretch now
to get to get this to get this bottom
row second column or second row second
column we multiply this row essentially
by this column right over here so it is
going to be
5 times four
five times four
plus three times negative six
plus three times negative six now what
is all of this what does all of this
simplify to
so this is going to be equal to
let's see
so negative 2
plus
negative 14 that's going to be negative
16.
that right over there is negative 16.
then we have 8
plus 12 so that's going to be 20
and then we have negative 5
plus
which is going to be 16
positive 16. did i do that right yep
positive 16
and then finally you're going to have 20
minus 18. so that's just going to be 2.
so the product of these two matrices we
deserve a little bit of a drum roll at
this point
when we multiply this 2 by 2 matrix
times this 2 by 2 matrix we are going to
get
negative 16
and
sixteen
and two
and we are done